ich rufe auf den Zusatzpunkt aktuelle
Stunde die Fraktion der AFD hat eine
Aktuelle Stunde verlangt zu dem Thema
Forderungen nach einem Kalifat in
Deutschland entschieden
entgegentrreten ich eröffne die
Aussprache das Wort hat der Abgeordnete
Sebastian münzenmeier für die afdaktion
ja die AFD Fraktion hat die aktuelle
Stunde beantragt und darf sie die
entsprechend auch
eröffnen sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
meine Damen und Herren am vergangenen
Freitag zogen tausende von Arabern durch
die Essener Innenstadt lauter
alleruakbarrufe schallen durch die
Straßen riesige Fahnen die stark an die
Fahnen der Terrororganisation is
erinnern bestimmen das Straßenbild
marschiert wird streng getrennt nach
Geschlechtern die Frauen sind voll
verschleiert Teilnehmer fordern die
Ausrufung eines Kalifats in Deutschland
und deutscher Anwohner trauen sich kaum
mehr auf die Straße nur wenige Stunden
später zieht ein weiterer Mop von über
8000 Fremden in düsterer Kolonne durch
Berlin der bekannte Neptunbrunnen wird
von mehreren randalieren erklettert und
wie bei Eroberungen üblich wird die
palästinafagge auf der Spitze des
Brunnens platziert jubelnde und
feigsende Ausländer Polizei und Staat
auf dem Rückzug Bilder die um die Welt
gehen und plötzlich scheinen sie von der
CDU bis hin zu den Grünen völlig
überrascht Grenzüberschreitung schimpft
CDU wüst in NRW akzeptabel Tönen selbst
die Grünen und nen sie fer fer regt sich
über die Überschreitung von roten Linien
auf welche Heuchelei wenn sich nun
plötzlich die einwanderungsfanatiker in
Sonntagsreden empören meine Damen und
Herren was unternimmt denn die Ampel was
unternehmen denn die ganzen
Ministerpräsidenten von wüst bis Söder
sie alle haben doch gerade heute morgen
wieder staatstragende Reden geschwungen
aber Goeth hat es mal so schön auf den
Punkt gebracht es genügt nicht zu wollen
man muss auch tun und sie tun gar nichts
die Grenzen sind sperrangelweit offen
Migration wird nicht gestoppt sondern
als fachkräfteinwanderung getahnt und
weiterhin angefeuert das
Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht wird
geschliffen deutsche Pässe für alle am
besten gleich morgen bevor sie sich also
alle künstlich aufregen und heuchlerisch
emphören sollten Sie sich die Frage
stellen wer hat denn diese Zustände in
unseren Städten eigentlich zu
verantworten und das meine Damen und
Herren sind Sie dass sieind die
zuwanderungsfans in allen Altparteien
all jene heimatfeindlichen Kräfte den
ein deutsches Deutschland stehs ein Dorn
im Auge war Deutschland wird sich
verändern und wir freuen uns drauf wir
erinnern uns noch gut das war doch ihr
Motto das war ihr Motto als die zentrale
Frage für die Zukunft unseres Landes
gestellt wurde ihnen allen konnte und
kann Deutschland doch überhaupt nicht
Bund genug sein und nun hat sich
Deutschland verändert und dort draußen
unter den Fahnen des Kalifats da
marschiert ihr bunter Traum ihr
Geschwätz von Fachkräften von
Bereicherung von Integration und von den
Raketen Wissenschaftlern all das löst
sich endgültig in Luft auf und
zurückbleleiben die Trümmer einer linken
Lebenslüge für die sie alle bereit waren
unser Land zu opfern meine Damen und
Herren deutsche
Stadtviertel deutsche Stadtviertel sind
doch mittlerweile die Rückzugsorte
radikaler Islamisten die Armee des
Kalifats rekrutiert sich aus der
herrschar der ungezügelten
Masseneinwanderung und die Schatztruhe
des Kalifats ist doch in Wahrheit
mittlerweile das deutsche Bürgergeld
ihre Politik kann überhaupt keine
Lösungen finden weil sie die das Problem
sind die Fremde Landnahme auf deutschen
Straßen ist nicht vom Himmel gefallen
sie ist die logische Konsequenz ihrer
verrückten Einwanderungspolitik meine
Damen und
Herren und wer jetzt dieses Problem
angeblich lösen will der kann sich doch
vor einer zentralen Frage nicht
wegducken in welchem Deutschland wollen
wir leben und wessen Deutschland soll
das überhaupt sein knapp 10 Jahre nach
dem willkommenswahnsinn von 2015 stellt
sich diese Frage wieder und dieses Mal
noch dringlicher und es wird immer
klarer erkennbar dass es in Zukunft nur
zwei Optionen geben kann entweder Chaos
Straßenschlachten und ethnische
Konflikte im bunten multikultistaat oder
ein Deutschland als Land der Deutschen
als Ort von Freiheit von Ordnung und von
Normalität und in dieser Frage meine
Damen und Herren da gibt es keinen
Kompromiss da gibt es nur ein entweder
oder und jeder einzelne hier im Haus
muss ich entscheiden wenn wir jetzt
nicht massiv gegensteuern dann werden
wir eine Zukunft erleben die mit der
Vorstellung eines selbst bewussten
freiheitlichen und demokratischen
Nationalstaats nichts mehr zu tun haben
wird das zeigt einen Blick in jede
demografische Statistik und in jede
deutsche Zeitung das Steig zeigt
mittlerweile auch ein Spaziergang durch
jede deutsche Stadt und jede Fahrt in
Bus oder Bahn heute sind es noch 3000
die das Kalifat fordern morgen
vielleicht 30.000 oder wollen wir warten
bis es 300.000 sind der radikale Islam
stellt im Deutschland im Jahr
2023 ganz offen die Machtfrage und wir
müssen diese mit allerhze beantworten
die Losung der Stunde lautet Remigration
und zwar millionenfache Remigration wer
jetzt hier aber rumschreit und von
Remigration nicht reden will der möge
schweigen wenn die Anhänger des Kalifats
in Zukunft durch unsere Straßen ziehen
meine Damen und Herren es zeigt sich
auch bei diesem Thema wieder einmal ganz
deutlich nur die Alternative für
Deutschland ist willens und in der Lage
die klare Aussage zu treffen die es
braucht mit uns wird es in Deutschland
kein Kalifat geben sondern eine rig
verabschiedungskultur denn Deutschland
ist unser Land und wir lassen es uns
nicht wegnehmen herzlichen
Dank sie haben das Wort zu einem
Geschäftsordnungsantrag und möchten
gerne die Herr beirufung der Ministerin
beantragen es ist hier ein zentrales
Problem der inneren Sicherheit nach
Paragraph 42 unserer Geschäftsordnung
und nach Grundgesetz
[Applaus]
bitte so ich wende mich an
Staatsminister wissen wir
etwas nein die Frage ist ja ich prüfe
gerade wie weit Entschuldigungen
vorliegen sie ist auf dem Weg
hög ja nee wir können ruhig in der
Debatte
Vorfahren 10
Minuten wir haben heute noch so ein
langen Tag vor uns das will die
afdaktion stimmt ja auch
nicht also wir haben zwei Möglichkeiten
wir haben die Möglichkeit den
Geschäftsordnungsantrag den der
Geschäftsführer der AFD Fraktion
ordnungsgemäß hier gestellt hat
abzustimmen oder wir haben die
Möglichkeit möglichst
zügig die Innenminister zu empfangen ich
höre genau
also also die Folge einer entsprechenden
Abstimmung ist natürlich auch klar weil
mit dem
Ergebnis genau wir würden so schnell wie
möglich die Ministerin hierher bekommen
wir haben jetzt die Info 10 Minuten ich
denke dass die AFD Fraktion bestimmt
auch daran interessiert ist dass die
Debatte in derzeit weitergeht wir haben
noch einen langen Tag vor uns und
deswegen
B wir die Debatte an der Stelle
[Musik]
weiterzuführen wenn eine Fraktion
Beratung wünscht und Unterbrechung muss
ich das machen deswegen ich gucke noch
mal ob es irgendwelche
Nachrichten ja dann haben wir ein
hammelsprung also ich kann Ihnen das
gerne erklären ist das
so gut gut also die SPD Fraktion
beantragt Abstimmung ist das
richtig dann stimmen wir über den
Geschäftsordnungsantrag des der AFD
Fraktion gestellt durch den
Parlamentarischen Geschäftsführer dieser
Fraktion ordnungsgemäß auf
herbeizitierung der Bundesministerin des
Innern und für Heimat hier
ab Herr Brandner sie sind gerade nicht
dran jetzt bin ich
dran wer stimmt für die
herbeizitierung das sind die Mitglieder
der AFD Fraktion wer stimmt
dagegen das sind die koalitionsfraktion
und die Fraktion DIE LINKE wer enthält
sich die CDU CSU Fraktion damit ist
dieser Antrag mit der Mehrheit des
Hauses abgelehnt wir fahren in der
Aktuellen Stunde
[Musik]
fort so jetzt gibt hier doch noch etwas
Lautstärke fürte Zuschauerinnen und
Zuschauer man muss jetzt erstmal genau
zuhören wie die
bundestagsvizpräsidentin PET verfährt es
gab den Antrag der AFD Fraktion nach 42
der Geschäftsordnung des Deutschen
Bundestages auf Herbeirufung eines
Mitglieds des Bundestages dieser Antrag
ist hier gestellt worden sie haben es
gehört aus der SPD Fraktion kam die
Information die bundesinnenministerin
die die AFD herbeizen zitieren wollte
die sei auf dem Weg dann gab es die
Möglichkeit beispielsweise auch die
Sitzung zu
unterbrechen dann gab es das noch
Beratungsbedarf vorne im Präsidium und
jetzt hören wir gerade noch mal Petra
Pau wie es hier weitergeht weitere
Abstimmungen wünschen den ich
entsprechend nachkommen muss nach der
Geschäftsordnung werde ich das machen
ansonsten bitte ich Sie jetzt den
Weiterführung der Aktuellen Stunde zu
ermöglichen und das Wort hat Daniel
Waldi für die SPD Fraktion also Petra
Pau hat in einfacher Abstimmung hier die
anwesenden Mitglieder die hier gerade im
Plenum waren gebeten über diesen
Geschäftsordnungsantrag abzustimmen das
war eine eindeutige Mehrheit die hier
gegen den Geschäftsordnungsantrag der
AFD zustande gekommen ist so geht es
also tatsächlich dann einfach hier
weiter mit dieser aktuellen Stunde und
wie gesagt die
bundesinnenministerin wurde ja hier auch
bereits angekündigt wir hören jetzt also
dem nächsten Redner mal zu Daniel Baldi
für die SPD Fraktion spricht
jetzt kommen wir zum Thema was bedeutet
denn ein Kalifat konkret es gibt in
einem Kalifat keine Meinungsfreiheit
keine Religionsfreiheit es gibt
Menschenrechte werden massiv beschnitten
und wo Regeln gebrochen werden da drohen
drakonische Strafen und folglich ist
doch absolut klar ein Kalifat ist nicht
mit dem Grundgesetz vereinbar und
Forderungen danach werden wir auch immer
entschieden zurückweisen liebe
Kolleginnen und
Kollegen aber diese aktuelle Stunde wird
doch nicht verhindern dass wieder
Menschen auf die Straßen gehen werden
und dieselbe dämliche falsche Forderung
stellen werden was also können wir tun
um zukünftig islamistische
Radikalisierung zu verhindern eine
Radikalisierung die sich doch nicht nur
in der kalifatforderung zeigt sondern
auch in den blanken zu verabscheuenden
Israelhass der letzten Wochen was genau
braucht es also um nicht nur solche
Demonstrationen sondern auch die
Entwicklung davor effektiv zu verhindern
eine Antwort darauf liefert
beispielsweise das Projekt wertraum aus
meinem Wahlkreis mein in Zusammenarbeit
mit dem
reheinlandfelsischen Justizministerium
bietet der Verein wertzeug Angebote zur
demokratiebildung und
extremismusprävention in Haftanstalten
an denn und das wissen wir doch alle
dass Haftanstalten eben ein
Brandbeschleuniger für Radikalisierung
sind nicht nur im Bereich Islamismus
sondern eben auch im politischen
Extremismus und was tun wir als
Ampelkoalition dagegen das
demokratieördergesetz wird die
Finanzierung von solchen Projekten wie
wertraum endlich auf auf solide Füße
stellen und wir sollten alle ein
Interesse daran haben das auch weiter zu
unterstützen und deshalb gilt heute mehr
denn je wer Extremismus Prävention
langfristig sichern will der muss auch
das demokratieördergesetz unterstützen
liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen aber natürlich gilt es nicht
nur radikale Ideologien in ihrer
Entstehung zu verhindern sondern auch
die Plattform zu bekämpfen auf denen
sich die Extremisten immer wieder
treffen vernetzen und weiter radikal und
genau deshalb war es auch so gut und
richtig dass die Innenministerin Nancy
Feser heute morgen hier im Plenum noch
einmal bekräftigt hat die Verbote von
Hamas und samidun waren absolut richtig
und es werden nicht die letzten Verbote
gewesen sein eines jedoch und das ist
besonders wichtig in der ganzen Debatte
sei es im Falle von Generation Islam sei
es bei anderen Gruppen wie
beispielsweise
nachfolgerorganisation von hisbu Tahir
oder anderen diese Verbote müssen auch
rechtssicher sein sie müssen gut
vorbereitet sein und genau dafür sorgt
unsere Bundesinnenminister und für uns
bundesinnenministerin und für uns als
Ampelkoalition gilt deshalb wir
befürworten diese Verbote ausdrücklich
und den Kurs der Ministerin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und zu guter
Letzt ist es wichtig dass wir über
islamischen Antisemitismus sprechen so
wie wir das heute tun das wurde in den
letzten Jahren vielleicht auch zu selten
getan lassen Sie mich Ihnen zur
Einordnung noch zwei Zahlen nennen
dieses Jahr oder bis mitte diesen Jahres
wurden 685 antisemitische Straftaten der
politisch motivierten Kriminalität recht
zugeordnet und 34 antisemitische
Straftaten wurden der politisch
motivierten Kriminalität aufgrund
religiöser oder ausländischer Ideologie
zugeordnet die Zahlen werden sich noch
bis Ende des Jahres verändern aber sie
sprechen doch heute schon für sich und
ihre eigene Verantwortung Liebe AFD
Fraktion beim Thema beim Thema
Antisemitismus die haben sie doch heute
und in den den letzten Wochen immer und
immer wieder verschwiegen ihr Kollege
sprach noch heute morgen hier im
Deutschen Bundestag in der Gedenkstunde
davon von angeblichen friedlichen
Demonstranten die sich im letzten Jahr
David Sterne anhefteten und die Schoa
aus widerlichste relativieren wo blieb
da ihre Empörung als börn höcke das
Denkmal für die ermordeten Juden Europas
ein Denkmal der Schande nannte wo blieb
da wo blieb da ihr Aufschrei und als
Alexander gauland die Schoa ein
Vogelschiss nannte wo blieb da ihre aktu
Stunde oder ähnliches es blieb immer und
immer wieder aus stattdessen machten Sie
Alexander gauland auch noch zu ihrem
Ehrenvorsitzenden und seit Beginn des
russischen andelskriegs auf die Ukraine
bedienen sie sich doch auch in reden
immer und immer wieder verstärkt auch
antisemitischer Sprache da reden sie von
geheimen globalen Eliten die anleblich
diese Republik steuern oder von einer
gewissen Fremdbestimmtheit all das
bedient antisemitische Klischees und
diesen Antisemitismus den erleben wir
doch nicht erst seit dem 7 Oktober seit
dem Überfall der Hamas auf Israel nein
den erleben wir bei Ihnen seit 10
Jahren im allgemeinen Trubel ist heen
vielleicht mein Hinweis
untergegangen ich weiß gerade nicht was
sie dort am Mikrofon tun herrfahle aber
während ich meinen Hinweis hier während
ich hier mein äh Hinweis erst einmal
gebe können Sie das aus Ermanglung eines
parlamentarischen Geschäftsführers hier
dem Präsidium mitteilen was ihr Begehr
ist und dann werden wir das auch alles
verhandeln kommen Sie einfach ein
Stückchen hier nach vorn so jetzt noch
mal zurück ich hatte bevor diese Debatte
weiter ich bin
es gab eine versuchte Wortmeldung eines
fraktionslosen
Abgeordneten der nach vorne gebeten wird
zum
Präsidium wir sind auch zur Erklärung
für diejenigen die jetzt neu zu uns
gekommen sind auf der besuchertribüe in
einer aktuellen Stunde die die AFD
beantragt hat und sind in der Debatte
und ich hatte vorhin ein Hinweis gegeben
der vielleicht ein wenig untergegangen
ist
viele
viele kennen das schon ich schaue mir
nachher gleich das Protokoll in Ruhe an
bitte aber von vorne rein sich einer
parlamentarischen Ausdrucksweise hier zu
befleißigen und sollte es Dinge geben
die zu Rügen sind werde ich das auch
entsprechend noch nachträglich tun
so ja die Situation war zwischenzeitlich
etwas unübersichtlich tatsächlich weil
dann doch einiges hier an Zwischenrufen
war als der geschäftsordn
derd kam und dann hat die
bundestagsvizpräsidentin die Möglichkeit
das eben entsprechend im Stenografen
Protokoll nachzulesen so in der
Aktuellen Stunde geht's weiter mit Nina
wen für die CDU CSU Fraktion sehr
geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen unsere
Demokratie und unsere Grundwerte sind
das Fundament unseres Landes sie sind
die Grundlage für Freiheit Vielfalt
Rechtsstaatlichkeit und den Respekt vor
den Menschenrechten und als cduc
verteidigen wir diese werde
leidenschaftlich und werden nicht
zulassen dass sie untergraben werden
dementsprechend scharf verurteilen wir
dass am vergangenen Wochenende auf
Demonstrationen mitten in Deutschland
Forderungen nach einem Kalifat gestellt
worden sind solche Forderungen stehen im
krassen Gegensatz zu unseren Grundwerten
und sind absolut
inakzeptabel wir können und wir werden
nicht hinnehmen dass islamistische
Extremist auf den Straßen unseres Landes
für ihre Ziele werben und ein Kalifat
fordern Ihnen sagen wir deutlich
Jüdinnen und Juden gehören in unser Land
ihr aber nicht es ist gerade in der
aktuellen emotional sehr aufgeheizten
Zeit wichtig nicht zu pauschalisieren
die überwältigende Mehrheit der
Migranten in Deutschland lebt friedlich
und respektiert unsere Werte wir dürfen
nicht zulassen dass Vorurteile oder
Diskriminierung diese Menschen treffen
als
ich 14 der Anführer der
Terrororganisation islamischer Staat in
Mossul zum Kalifen ausrief sind viele
Menschen genau vor einem derartigen
Kalifat geflohen weil sie entsprechend
unseren Werten frei friedlich und sicher
leben wollen diese Menschen haben in
Deutschland inzwischen ein Zuhause
gefunden in dem Sie gerne und gut
integriert leben Aufgabe dieser
Musliminnen und Muslime ist es nun auch
sich gemeinsam mit uns gegen
Antisemitismus in ihren Reihen und im
ganzen Land zu stellen liebe Kollegen
Kollegin und Kollegen wir müssen aber
auch den Tatsachen ins Auge blicken dass
nicht alle die zu uns gekommen sind sich
mit unseren Werten identifizieren und
hier offenbar eine Integration in unsere
offene freie und demokratische
Gesellschaft bislang eben nicht geglückt
ist diese Menschen genießen alle
Freiheiten Vorzüge und Annehmlichkeiten
eines rechtsstaatlichen Landes und
fordern gleichzeitig eine Staatsform die
all diese Dinge verachtet und mit Füßen
tritt wir müssen anerkennen werte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen dass es im Land
verschiedene Formen des Antisemitismus
gibt aber besonders der muslimische
Antisemitismus eben weit verbreitet ist
ein Problem das natürlich auch durch
Zuwanderung in unser Land gekommen ist
lassen sie uns nicht im Stiel und mit
den Schlussfolgerungen der AFD darüber
sprechen aber verschließen wir davor
auch nicht die Augen liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen wir sind der Überzeugung
dass Integration und Teilhabe wichtige
Schlüsselfaktoren sind um Extremismus
und radikalen ien vorzubeugen hier
müssen wir unsere Bemühungen weiter
verstärken wir setzen uns dafür ein dass
Migranten in Deutschland Unterstützung
und Bildung erhalten die Sie benötigen
um sich erfolgreich und nachhaltig in
unsere Gesellschaft zu integrieren dabei
muss unter anderem in den
Integrationskursen verdeutlicht werden
dass Antisemitismus in jeglicher Form
mit unseren Grundwerten unvereinbar ist
und wir müssen dafür sorgen dass gerade
die vielen zu uns gekommenen Kinder und
Jugendliche unsere aufgeklärten
westlichen Werte annehmen und da gilt es
eben jetzt anzusetzen bevor es zu spät
ist und liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
in diesem Zusammenhang würden wir uns
auch wünschen dass die
Integrationsbeauftragte der
Bundesregierung endlich sich auch aus
der Deckung wagt und sich um ihren
eigentlichen gesetzlichen Auftrag
kümmert und nicht nur rassismusberichte
verfasst liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Integration ist aber keine Einbahnstraße
neben den Integrationsbemühungen ist es
auch unsere Aufgabe diejenigen zu
identifizieren die solche
extremistischen Forderungen unterstützen
und geeignete und konsequente
konsequente Maßnahmen zu ergreifen wir
setzen uns für eine konsequente
Überwachung extremistischer Gruppen und
die Verfolgung derer ein die Gewalt oder
Radikalisierung fördern wir wollen und
werden unsere Sicherheitsbehörden
weiterhin stärken und die notwendigen
Ressourcen zur Verfügung stellen um
unser Land vor Bedrohungen von innen und
von außen zu schützen dazu gehört auch
eine verstärkte strafrechtliche Ahung an
dies tischer Äußerungen mit einer
mindestfreiheitsstrafe von 6 Monaten und
dazu gehört auch dass eine
antisemitische Straftat bei geflüchteten
in der Regel zur Ausweisung
führt die Bilder aus Essen und Berlin
haben uns einmal mehr aktuell vor Augen
geführt dass Bedrohungen durch
antidemokratische Kräfte immer bestehen
und wir als Demokraten sie bekämpfen
müssen gerade deshalb dürfen wir aber
auch nicht zulassen dass die AFD diese
Bilder und Geschehnisse nun wieder
versucht auszunutzen um Ängste und
Vorurteile zu schüren und unsere
Gesellschaft zu spalten in diesen Zeiten
Werte Kollegen ist es besonders wichtig
dass wir als Gesellschaft zusammenstehen
und unsere Werte verteidigen wir dürfen
nicht länger tolerant sein gegenüber
denjenigen die unsere tolerante
freiheitliche Gesellschaft abschaffen
wollen vielen Dank sagt n Wagen für die
Unionsfraktion ja nach der umstrittenen
Demonstration in Essen da hat jetzt auch
der Innenminister von nordrinwestfah
Herbert re ein Verbot von drei
islamistischen Gruppierungen gefordert
beispielsweise Maßnahmen gegen die
sogenannte Generation Islam die auch
aktiv gewesen sein soll rund und um die
Demonstration in Essen 2014 hat der
Terrorist abuakr al bagdadi über Gebiete
des Iraks und Syrien das angebliche
Kalifat des sogenannten islamischen
Staates ausgerufen dabei Vertrieb und
tötete er Tausende von Menschen in
dieser Region all das giipelte später in
einem entsetzlichen Genozid an
jesidinnen und Jesiden ein Genozid in
dem sexualisierte Gewalt gegen Frauen
Massenhinrichtungen und versksklavung
einen gezielten Terror entfesselten dass
Menschen auf deutschen Straßen erneut
zur Gründung eines solchen Kalifats
aufrufen ist
abscheulich das schwarze Benner die es
vom oder auch von der genutzt wird zu
tragen ist gerade für mich als Muslimen
besonders erschreckend und abstoßend
vermutlich dürfte es fast allen Muslim
hierzulande so ähnlich gehen sind doch
Muslime weltweit die meisten Opfer von
Islamisten die Bilder der
propagandchauen Essen zeigen uns der
Islamismus ist und bleibt eine reale
Bedrohung für unsere freiheitlich
demokratische Grundordnung für
Nichtmuslime und für Muslime jetzt
instrumentalisiert jetzt
instrumentalisiert er zum wiederholten
Male den ostkonflikt seine Propaganda im
Netz und auf deutschen Straßen zu
verbreiten soweit eigentlich nichts
Neues die Gefahr des Islamismus war
niemals verschwunden alle wen wir warten
wir stetig davor sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren unser Rechtsstaat ist hier
gefordert alle ihm zur Verfügung
stehende Mittel einzusetzen um dieser
islamistischen Bedrohung wirksam
entgegenzutreen dazu
gehören dazu gehören unter anderem
solide begründete Verbote von Kundgebung
und die strafrechtliche Verfolgung von
volksverhetzenden Rede weiträgen
verfassungsfeindlichen Symbolen dazu
gehört auch die islamistische Szene
genau zu überwachen um frühzeitig auf
Gefahren reagieren zu können und ja dazu
gehört auch die im Aufenthaltsgesetz
schon jetzt bestehende Möglichkeit der
Ausweisung von denjenigen die die
öffentliche Sicherheit und Ordnung
gefährden wir werden uns von
islamistinnen und Islamisten nicht auf
der Nase herumtanzen lassen meine Damen
und
Herren die Strategie des Islamismus
besteht wie bei allen anderen radikal
Ideologien darin Emotionalisierung zu
nutzen und einfache Antworten auf
komplexe Fragen zu liefern das dürfte
der AFD also sehr bekannt vorkommen man
weiß nicht ob man weinen oder lachen
soll oder doch zum Lachen ist es
wirklich nicht dass sie mit ihren
hinlänglich bekannten immer gleichen
eindimensionalen und
menschenverachtenden Anträgen auch noch
am 9 November um die Ecke kommen
ausgerechnet am 85 jahrestag der reisbur
gromncht man kann eigentlich nur mit den
Kopf schütteln es macht mich
fassungslos
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen eine der
Lebensadern des Islamismus ist das
narrativ dass die nichtmuslimische
Mehrheitsgesellschaft Muslimen Muslimen
hasse und andersherum lebt
Islamfeindlichkeit von dem narrativ
Islamismus bzw jeder Nichtmuslim ist ein
Islamhasser also das heißt es gibt eine
wechselbewirkung zwischen Islamismus und
Islamfeindlichkeit diese Strategie des
Islamismus müssen wir durchkreuzen indem
wir zeitgleich auch gegen
Islamfeindlichkeit vorgehen denn wenn
wir nur den islamis bekämpfen und
Islamfeindlichkeit nicht bleibt ein
Phänomen bestehen das weiterhin
mobilisiert und wiederum den Islamismus
anfacht damit ist die AFD damit ist die
AFD natürlich raus aus dem Thema sie hat
bis heute nicht verstanden dass die
kübelweise Wasser auf die Mühl der
Islamisten gießt und damit die
gefähdungslage für alle friedlichen
Menschen in diesem Land nach oben
schraubt oder
aber oder aber na ja wenn es nicht so
weh tun würde und wenn ich nicht recht
hätte würden sie sich nicht aufregen
oder aber sieoh standen und spielt genau
damit um weitere Ängste in der
Gesellschaft zu schüren sie liefert mit
ihrem immer wieder artikulierten
antimuslimischen Rassismus den
näherboden auf dem Islamismus besonders
gut gedeihen kann sie und ihr heutiger
ant Antrag sind nicht Teil der Lösung
sondern Teil des
Problems aber es geht hier nicht um die
AFD es geht um Islamismus und um keine
Missverständnisse aufkommen zu lassen
der existiert auch ohne eine AFD sie
sind allerdings der
Brandbeschleuniger
ich möchte dass das geprüft wird dass
meine ehemaligen Schüler wegen mir zum
erst gegangen sind das verbitte ich mir
an dieser Stelle das verbitte ich mir an
dieser
Stelle nein das verbitte ich mir an
dieser Stelle es ist schlicht weg falsch
dass sie mir einen Anteil an diesem
Schwachsinn unterstellen also ehrlich
geht's noch geht es noch hören Sie mal
also ich glaube ich wirklich das ist
unfassbar was sie hier machen unfassbar
was sie hier machen
der Wahrheit welcher W ich habe gerade
die die Uhr
angehalten so ich bitte er einmal um
allgemeine Mäßigung und wiederhole nun
zum dritten Mal innerhalb weniger
Minuten dass es inzwischen leider das
tägliche Geschäft der Präsidentin und
des Präsidenten ist dass wir natürlich
jedes Protokoll unserer Plenarsitzung
ordentlich prüfen um erstens jeder
Abgeordneten und jedem Abgeordneten zu
seinem Recht zu verhelfen und sollte es
regelüberschreitung Grenzüberschreitung
gegeben haben werden die gegebenenfalls
auch nachträglich geandet so
und ich erwarte jetzt dass auch die
antragstellende Fraktion auf deren
Veranlassung wir hier in der Debatte
sind dafür sorgt dass wir auch weiter in
die Debatte kommen können und werd jetzt
die Uhr für den Rest der Redezeit ich
schlage auf die Zeit die bei mir hier
angezeigt wird und vorne am Pult noch
mal 10 Sekunden drauf da das vorhin im
allgemeinen Trubel unterging bitte sie
haben das Wort dann fahre ich gerne fort
mit dem letzten Satz meine Schüler sind
zu mir erst gegangen zu dem Zeitpunkt
als sie nicht mehr meine Schüler waren
sollten Sie das noch ein einziges Mal
hier öffentlich oder nicht öffentlich
wiederholen bekommen sie von Anzeige
dafür ganz einfach vielen Dank meine
Damen und
Herren Lia kad war das von den Grünen
sie hat vor einigen Jahren schon ein
Buch darüber
[Musik]
geschrieben als sie noch Lehrerin war in
dienstlagen für islamischen
Religionsunterricht an einer
Sekundarschule unter anderem mit mehr
als 1000 Schülern muslimischen Glaubens
die sie unterrichtet hat dort in der
Schule und von der AFD Fraktion gab es
Zwischenrufe die zurüesen hat
vergangenen Wochen wurden auf Kundgebung
und Demonstration Forderungen formuliert
und Transparente hochgehalten die
verstörend sind und die nicht toleriert
werden können und
deshalb möchte ich für mich und meine
Fraktion ganz klar sagen für
Antisemitismus und und islamistischen
Extremismus kann es keine Rechtfertigung
geben
diechte in der israelischen Armee in
Gaza rechtfertigt weder den Hass auf
Jüdinnen und Juden noch irgendwelche
abstrusen Forderungen nach einem
kalifatstaat wie sie vergangenen Freitag
in Essen aufgestellt wurden eins möchte
ich aber auch ganz klar sagen wir linke
stellen uns gegen den islamistischen
Extremismus der mit Antisemitismus
einhergeht genauso wie gegen den
antimuslimischen Rassismus der
AFD wir sind gegen jede Form der
bezogenen Menschen Feindlichkeit egal
wen sie gerichtet ist oder aus welcher
Ecke sie kommt und in Wirklichkeit geht
es der AFD ja gar nicht um den Schutz
jüdischen Lebens in Deutschland es geht
ihr um die Pflege ihres lieblingsthemas
und lieblingsfeindbildes um den Islam
und die angebliche Islamisierung
Deutschlands sie hetzt wieder einmal
gegen eingewanderte und geflüchtete sie
versucht Angst und Hetze zu schüren und
diesem Versuch müssen wir auch heute und
immer und immer wieder
entgegenstellen meine Damen und Herren
ich möchte daran erinnern dass die AFD
die Partei ist die die nazit als
Vogelschiss der Geschichte bezeichnet
und eine erinnerungspolitische Wende um
180° in ihrem Programm fordert 2018 als
die Rechtsextremen Freunde der AFD
Migrantinnen und Migranten durch
kämnisjagten richteten sich die
Übergriffe des Mobs nicht nur gegen
eingewanderte sondern auch gegen das
einzige jüdische Restaurant in der
Stadt und deshalb ist es mehr als
verlogen wenn die AFD sich jetzt als
Beschützerin jüdischen Lebens heute hier
in dieser Debatte
inszeniert meine Damen und Herren der
schreckliche Überfall der islamistischen
Hamas auf Israel hat einen neuen Krieg
losgetreten über 1200 Menschen wurden
getötet die zahlreichen Morde die
massiven raketenbeschüsse und die
Berichte über Entführung sind
schockierend der Versuch der
israelischen Armee die Hamas zu
bekämpfen geht mit großen Zerstörung und
zahllosen zivilen Opfer einher
mittlerweile sind tausende zivile Opfer
zu beklagen dadunter Kinder ältere
Menschen JournalistInnen die humanitäre
Lage ist katastrophal die
Gesundheitsversorgung nicht mehr
gewährleistet und das Mobilfunk Netz
nicht mehr funktionsfähig
Waffenstillstand humanitäre Hilfe
Verhandlung Dialog sind dringend
notwendig
es ist daher auch besonders
begrüßenswert wenn Bundespräsident Frank
Walter Steinmeier nun betont dass die
palästinensische Gemeinschaft in
Deutschland Raum haben muss um ihren
Schmerz und ihre Verzweiflung über die
zivilen Opfer in Gaza zu zeigen doch der
Kampf gegen Antisemitismus ist
Bürgerpflicht und deshalb ist es nicht
nur Aufgabe der arabischstämmigen
Menschen sich von Extremismus und
Antisemitismus zu distanzieren und es
ist auch nicht so dass alle Muslime in
unserer Gesellschaft in besonderer Weise
verpflichtet sind sich zu distanzieren
wie Vizekanzler Robert habck meint denn
eine solche Erwartungshaltung setzt
Moslims und arabischstämmige Menschen in
unserer Gesellschaft unter
Generalverdacht und sie relativiert den
weit verbreiteten Antisemitismus in der
gesamten Gesellschaft bei den rund 3000
erfassten antisemitischen Straftaten
2021 waren rund
84,3% rechtsextreme Täter der Kampf
gegen Antisemitismus ist daher eine
gesamtgesellschaftliche Aufgabe und er
kann nicht getrennt werden vom Kampf
gegen jede Form von gruppenbezogener
Menschenfeindlichkeit dafür setzen wir
uns ein und die AFD ist nicht die
Alternative für die Zukunft Deutschlands
sondern für den Untergang vielen
[Applaus]
Dank für die LE für
Migrationspolitik so nächste Rednerin in
dieser aktuellen Stunde wird sein die
Abgeordnete Sandra bubendorfer Licht für
die FDP Fraktion sie ist
religionspolitische Sprecherin der
Liberalen sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen unter dem
vermeintlichen Deckmantel der Humanität
sind den Essen
gewaltverherlichende und uns und und
unserer Lebensweise feindlich gesinnte
Islamisten auf die Straßen gegangen das
war keine pro palästiner Demo das war
eine Demonstration gegen unsere Werte
gegen die Freiheit gegen die
Gleichberechtigung gegen den Westen und
gegen den Anstand es war eine
Provokation eine
Machtdemonstration des politischen
Islamismus in unserem Land unsere
Botschaft kann nur sein wir überlassen
diesen Fanatikern nicht das Feld und
werden mit allen Mitteln und Härten des
Rechtsstaats darauf
antworten die Ursprünge und letztendlich
die Konsequenz dieser Entwicklung liegt
aber tiefer den die dort verwendeten
Fahnen lassen auf einen klaren Bezug zur
hisfut Tahir Bewegung schließen die
bereits 2003 mit einem Betätigungsverbot
belegt wurde die heutigen abbleger
dieser kalifatsbewegung sind besonders
in den sozialen Medien wie Generation
Islam oder Realität Islam aktiver denn
je und indoktrinieren für solche
aufmärche natürlich gerade im Internet
besonders junge Muslime sie nehmen sich
vordergründig den Problem und Ängsten
von jungen Muslimen an zeigen
Verständnis und Zuneigung aber
beeinflussen sie gegen die vermeintlich
rassistische westliche
Mehrheitsgesellschaft und für die
rückbesinung auf den politischen
Islamismus und den Weg hin zum
Kalifat diese Indoktrinierung und man
Manipulierung zeigt leider Erfolg und
das ist eine der bitteren Lehren aus
Essen meine sehr verhrten Damen und
Herren wir haben es in Deutschland über
viele Jahre leider verpasst unsere
Politik und unseren staatlichen
Austausch mit Muslimen in unserem Land
nachhaltig umzusetzen und in Bahnen zu
lenken der ein Islam europäischer
Prägung hervorbringen
umso wichtiger ist es nun jetzt diese
entsetzlichen und fanatischen Triebe
auch zu unterbinden was wir aber
langfristig in Deutschland erreichen
müssen ist eine religionspolitische
Wende in Bezug auf das muslimische Leben
in den moscheegemeinschaft in
Deutschland in der Islamkonferenz haben
wir dabei seit 2006 die zentralen Fragen
wie den Umgang mit Antisemitismus oder
die Problematik von ausländischen
Strukturen innerhalb der Verbände leider
nicht angepackt und der oberste Dienst
der ditip Mosche in Deutschland der
Präsident der türkischen
Religionsbehörde dianet Ali
Erb den jüdischen Glauben als Perversion
bezeichnet und sein Vorgesetzter Erdogan
sich mit heramas solidarisiert kann es
in diesen Strukturen kein weiter so
geben und da kann sich die diep ihre
Brüder im Geiste auch nicht hinter
pressitteilung mit wach
ja aber Argumentation verstecken die
Sicherheit Israels ist unsere staatsres
unsere besondere Verpflichtung aus der
unbegreiflichen Schuld unserer
Geschichte und nur ein Islam der auch
diesen Grundsatz anerkennt kann ein
Islam sein der in Deutschland seinen
festen Platz in unserer freien
Gesellschaft
hat da kann es keine Unklarheit keine
Relativierung und keine Zugeständnisse
geben und ich weiß es gibt diese über
übergroße Mehrheit der in Deutschland
lebenden Muslime die tagtäglich in
unserer Gesellschaft einen so wichtigen
Beitrag leisten und die dieses Land und
diese Werte auch ihre Heimat nennen ich
kann an diese Menschen nur appellieren
seid laut und klar distanziert euch
gegenüber den Extremisten und dem
politischen Islam diese unserer Werte
und unserer Demokratie dürfen nicht die
Deutungshoheit über den Islam in
Deutschland für sich beanspruchen
herzlichen
[Applaus]
Dank das Wort hat der Abgeordnete Martin
Hess für die
AFD
frau Präsidentin meine sehr vererehrten
Damen und Herren der politische Islam
stellt in Deutschland die Machtfrage und
die Ampelkoalition gibt die falsche
Antwort das aggressive und gewalttätige
islamistische Gruppierungen in den
letzten Wochen nah zuu ungehindert durch
unsere Straßen ziehen ist eine Schande
für unseren Rechtsstaat und beweist dann
Neut dass diese Ampelkoalition in im
Interesse der Sicherheit unseres Landes
so schnell wie möglich abgelöst werden
muss aber auch die CDU die ja in einigen
Bundesländern regiert offenbart in einer
für unseren Rechtsstaat beschämenden
Weise ihre Unfähigkeit bei der
Bekämpfung gewalttätiger und
antisemitischer Islamisten ihr
Ministerpräsident in nordreheinwestfalen
her wüst hat großspurig verkündet man
werde islamistische Aufmärsche zukünftig
nicht mehr zulassen und keine vier
Wochen später haben islamistische
Staatsfeinde in Essen und Düsseldorf
gezeigt was von den Worten eines CDU
Ministerpräsidenten zu halten ist
nämlich gar nichts die haben sich völlig
unbehelligt frei bewegt und damit steht
fest auch die CDU ist nachweisbar nicht
in der Lage Sicherheit in Deutschland
herzustellen und wenn alle anderen beim
Schutz unserer Demokratie und unserer
Bürger Versagen führt kein Weg mehr an
der AFD vorbei denn wir sind die
einzigen mit dem unbedingten Willen den
politischen Islam mit aller hatte zu
bekämpfen einen glaubhaften Schutz
unserer Gesellschaft und unserer
Demokratie kann es deshalb nur mit der
AFD geben insbesondere das Versagen der
ampelregierung begründet sich vor allem
in einer völlig verfehlten
sicherheitspolitischen Fokussierung auf
den Rechtsextremismus aber jeder Bürger
dieses Landes sieht in diesen Wochen mit
seinen eigenen Augen was in unserem Land
tatsächlich das größte
Sicherheitsproblem ist nämlich der durch
ihre verheerende Migrationspolitik in
unserem Land immer stolker werdenende
Islamismus der immer radikaler der immer
brutaler wird und seine wahre
staatsfeindliche Gesinnung zeigt indem
er wie in Essen Geschehen den Kampf
aller Muslime gegen den Rest der Welt
und die Ausrufung eines Kalifats fordert
und angesichts dieser massiven Gefahr
für uns alle hat die AFD schon immer
einen klaren Standpunkt der heute
wichtiger ist denn je jetzt muss Schluss
sein mit ihrem Appeasement gegenüber dem
politischen Islam wir müssen diesen stat
zweiten ein für alle mal klar machen wer
Herr im Haus ist und wenn sie dazu nicht
in der Lage sind dann machen sie Platz
für die die es können die AFD steht
bereit wir müssen jetzt endlich ein
klares Zeichen der Stärke setzen wir
müssen beweisen dass unser Staat
wehrhaft ist und ich sage Ihnen wie man
mit islamistischen aufmerschen umzugehen
hat die in unserem Staat islamistische
Macht demonstrieren wollen und dabei
massive Straftaten begehen diese sind
sofort aufzulösen die Teilnehmer
festzunehmen und unverzüglich
abzuschieben und das gilt im übrigen
auch für alle islamistischen
Hassprediger und Gefährder unser Land
unsere Regeln und wer sich nicht dran
hält der hat hier nichts zu suchen und
wo Abschiebungen nicht möglich sind dort
hat die justizhte Urteile zu fällen
Bewährungsstrafen reichen hier nicht aus
solche Leute müssen ins Gefängnis auch
ihre falsche einbürgungspolitik muss
unverzüglich korrigiert werden
Islamisten die neben der unseren noch
weitere Staatsangehörigkeiten besitzen
ist die deutsche ohne Wenn und Aber zu
entziehen und dafür Sorge zu tragen dass
zukünftig kein einziger Islamist mehr
die deutsche Staatsangehörigkeit erhält
und natürlich müssen wir auch effektiv
unterbinden dass Islamisten weiterhin in
großer Zahl in unser Land strömen und
dafür muss endlich der von der AFD seit
2015 geforder der effektive Grenzschutz
der alle illegal Einreisen an der Grenze
zurückweist umgesetzt werden wenn wir
jetzt nicht handeln wird sich der
politische Islam in unserem Land immer
weiter ausbreiten das können und dürfen
wir im Interesse unserer Kinder nicht
zulassen der politische Islam gehört
nicht zu Deutschland und deshalb ist
auch jegliche Kooperation und jede
staatliche Förderung von Islamverbänden
die diese Ideologie vertreten fördern
oder unterstützen sofort einzustellen
und die ausländische Finanzierung zu
unterbinden wenn der der Staat seine
eigenen Feinde hofiert und finanziert
macht er sich nicht nur lächerlich
sondern er gefährdet und beschädigt
unsere Demokratie und kommen Sie mir
bitte nicht ständig damit dass die
Forderung der AFD rechtlich nicht
umsetzbar wären ich kann diesen Satz
nicht mehr hören Politiker sind dazu da
die zur Lösung eines Problems
erforderlichen Rechtsgrundlagen zu
schaffen und indem sie sich dieser
Aufgabe ständig verweigern betätigen Sie
sich als Totengräber s Rechtsstaates und
genau deshalb darf man ihnen auch nicht
länger die Sicherheit Deutschlands
überlassen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen gestatten Sie mir den Hinweis
dass um
15:59 uh die abstimmungsuren zu den
Wahlen zu einem Stellvertreter der
Präsidentin und zu Mitgliedern des Pkg
geschlossen werden wer also noch keine
Gelegenheit hatte zu wählen sollte sich
jetzt auf den Weg machen wir fahren fort
in der Aktuellen Stunde das Wort hat für
die SPD Fraktion Simona
Koss sie ist Mitglied im Ausschuss für
Inneres sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
der heutige 9 November der jahrestag der
Reichsprogromnacht vor 85 Jahren steht
unter dem Eindruck des brutalen Angriffs
der Hamas auf
Israel die AFD versucht mit dieser
aktuellen Stunde das Problem des
Antisemitismus in Deutschland einseitig
in Richtung Muslime zu verschieben und
sie versucht wieder kräftig Stimmung zu
machen sie beweist damit einmal mehr
dass sie keinen Respekt vor der Würde
des heutigen Tages hat
ja die Vorkommnisse des letzten
Wochenendes in Essen und Berlin bedürfen
der Aufarbeitung wer das demokratische
Versammlungsrecht nutzt um islamistische
Ideen zu vertreten der hat grundsätzlich
etwas nicht verstanden und das muss
geahnet werden ich bin froh dass unsere
Innenministerin neneser sofort reagiert
hat sie sagte ich darf
zitieren wir da sehen mussten ist mit
unserem Verständnis von Demokratie mit
unserer Vorstellung des friedlichen
Zusammenlebens in unserer demokratischen
Gesellschaft nicht
vereinbart und gestern im Innenausschuss
wir tolerieren nicht dass ein Islam
islamischer Gottesstaat auf unseren
Straßen propagiert wird vielen Dank Frau
Ministerin für die klaren
Worte
amutigen Verfolgung von Jüden und Juden
und was passiert die AFD greift das
Stichwort der Islamisten auf und will
hier über das Gespenst eines kalifates
debattieren wie tief sitzen eigentlich
ihre Reflexe dass sie nicht einmal an
diesem Tag zu differenzierter
Betrachtung fähig sind sie nutzen das
Gedenken um antimuslimisch restim zu
spüren sie nutzen das Gedenken um
Menschen gegeneinander aufzuhetzen das
ist das Geschäft der AFD und ihr sind
alle mittelrecht das ist schändlich und
eine Zumutung für dieses Haus meine
Damen und
Herren es geht nur zur Erinnerung heute
darum dass Jüdinnen und Juden auch im 85
Jahr nach der Reichsprogromnacht nicht
unbeschwert in diesem Land leben können
dies ist eine furchtbare Erkenntnis und
wir müssen konstatieren der aktuelle
Antisemitismus kam nicht über Nacht er
war nie weg wir kennen alle die
Statistiken dr Felix Klein der
antisemitismusbeauftragte der
Bundesregierung hat gestern neue Zahlen
vorgestellt über 90% der antisemitischen
Straftaten gehen auf das Konto von
Rechtsextremisten da gibt es nichts zu
relativieren die
die AFD und wir hören es will jetzt
ablenken und zeigt mit dem Finger auf
Muslimin und Muslime
übrigens ich bin Abgeordnete aus
Brandenburg bei uns leben kaum Muslime
und es gibt kaum sichtbares jüdisches
Leben erklären Sie mir bitte mal warum
ausgerechnet bei uns die Zahl der
antisimitischen Vorfälle so hoch ist H
vielleicht liegt es sogar an der großen
Zahl der AFD Politiker wäre ja eine
Idee das Lagebild Antisemitismus hat
Risse in der genkkultur aufgedeckt
spätestens seit der höckerede 2017 in
Dresden daran schließt der
Antisemitismus auf deutschen Straßen
nahlos an rechtsextreme und Islamisten
sind sich einig in der Ablehnung unserer
Erinnerungskultur rechtsextreme und
Islamisten sind sich auch einig in ihren
antisemitischen
vernichtungsfantasien das meine Damen
und Herren ist eine gefährliche
Verbindung für unsere
Demokratie heute Vormittag haben wir
unseren Entschließungsantrag historische
Verantwortung wahrnehmen mehr jüdisches
Leben in Deutschland Stützen mehr dort
haben wir mehr als 50 konkrete Maßnahmen
vorgeschlagen um den abscheulichen
Angriffen auf jüdisches Leben in
Deutschland und Israel etwas ent
Zusetzen der Antrag nimmt auch die
muslimische Community in die Pflicht es
ist richtig und gut dass unser
Bundespräsident gestern das Gespräch mit
Akteuren der interkulturellen
Verständigung gesucht hat denn ich
zitiere aus unserem Antrag die
Verantwortung jeglichen Antisemitismus
zu bekämpfen ist ganz ausdrücklich nicht
die Aufgabe der in Deutschland lebenden
Jüdinnen und Juden alle Akteure unseres
Landes vom Staat über die Parteien bis
hin zu zivilgesellschaftlichen
Organisation sind hier in der Pflicht
auch mein wir meine Damen und Herren
sind gemein eindeutig Stellung zu
beziehen ganz besonders an dem Tag
herzlichen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit das Wort hat Philip amtor
für die CDU und
CSU
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wer in Deutschland ein Kalifat
einführen will der hat in diesem Land
nichts zu suchen und wer in Deutschland
ein Kalifat einführen will der hat die
volle Härte des Rechtsstaates verdient
wer allerdings hier im Parlament eine
Aktuelle Stunde aufsetzt in einer
Problemlage die real ist mit irregulärer
Migration mit der Behauptung es drohte
tatsächlich die Errichtung eines
Kalifats in Deutschland der hat sich
auch aus der seriösen Debatte
verabschiedet liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen das gehört doch auch zur
Wahrheit und ich sage Ihnen auch ich
finde das ja alles gut wenn sie sagen
wir müssen mehr tun für den Schutz der
Jüdinnen und Juden in Deutschland das
ist richtig das ist aber unglaubwürdig
von einer Partei die den billigen
Applaus hinnimmt von den wildesten
schwörungstheoretikern die der jüdischen
Weltrevolution das Wort reden schaffen
sie dort Klarheit Ken sie vor ihrer
eigenen Tür dann wird das auch
glaubwürdig was sie hier vortragen
wollen aber ich muss in dieser Debatte
schon auch sagen es ist auch die
Verantwortung der Bundesregierung und
der Ampel dass der AFD und anderen so
viel Raum gegeben wird dieses Thema so
aufzubringen denn sie sind es die auch
Klarheit und Selbstkritik im Umgang mit
diesen islamistischen aufmärchen
vermissen lassen denn eines ist klar ja
es hat zu tun auch mit der schlimmen
Situation im Nahen Osten aber es ist
doch vor allem unerräglich für alle
Jüdinnen und Juden in unserem Land was
wir hier teilweise an Relativierungen
für diese aufmärscher erleben Liebe
kollegenin und Kollegen und ich sage das
hat nichts mehr zu tun mit einer
Solidaritätsaktion mit
das ist eine
Machtdemonstration gegen den deutschen
Staat und das ist auch Ausdruck
gescheiterter linker Integrationspolitik
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen und das
müssen wir in dieser Klarheit benennen
und es ist doch absurd Menschen die aus
Syrien aus Afghanistan aus dem Irak zu
uns geflohen sind vor dem Terror von is
vor den Taliban vor alkaida die sind es
jetzt die es zulassen die es teilweise
mit unterstützen das diese Symbole dass
die Ideen des Kalifats in Deutschland
publik gemacht werden oder noch
schlimmer es sind Menschen die in
Deutschland aufgewachsen sind
radikalisiert in einem Klima von
religiösem Hass und für uns ist klar das
können wir uns als Staat nicht bieten
lassen liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und ich sage auch es ist das Resultat
einer linken Integrationspolitik die
sich viel zu lange darin erschöpf hat
Tagträumereien vom bunten Straß fest
Multikulti zu feiern und zu schweigen
über die Schattenseiten von
gescheiterter Integration und hier ist
kein Platz für Relativierung das muss in
dieser Klarheit hier im Parlament
genannt werden liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und wenn ich dann sage es ist
kein Raum für
Relativierungen dann will ich auch
ansprechen Frau Kollegin kador von den
Grünen dass ich es mehr als befremdlich
finde wenn sie dann in einer deutschen
Talkshow davoned
mit Blick auf diese Aufmärsche die dort
vorkommen es ginge um migrantische
Wutbürger die endlich ein Ventil
gefunden hätten liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen in aller Klarheit wir lassen
uns als
Mehrheitsgesellschaft nicht die
Verantwortung für gescheiterte
Integration einzelner überhelfen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und es muss
Schluss sein mit dieser
Relativierung jetzt eine Islamkonferenz
eine nachtagung der Islamkonferenz zu
veranstalten Frau Innenministerin mit
dem Thema der
muslimfeindlichkeit das ist doch aus der
Zeit gefallen ja und sie haben im
Programm noch ein bisschen
antisemitismusbekämpfung dazu
geschrieben es reicht in diesen Tagen
nicht die
antisemitismusbekämpfung dazu
zuschreiben sondern es muss klar sein
das was an Relativierung mit Blick auf
Extremismus aus dem politischen Islam an
den Tag gelegt wurde das war Verklärung
hier braucht es eine echte Wende und die
muss auch aus diesem Parlament klar
gesendet werden liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und das schlimmste ist das was
sie veranstalten indem sie nicht genug
Kritik an den Tag legen indem sie nicht
zur kertwende bereit sind das ist eine
Last die im Moment vor allem zu tragen
ist von den vielen Liberalen Muslimen in
unserem Land die verdienen dass man
Klarheit schafft gegen religiösen
Extremismus und dazu sind sie noch nicht
in der Lage dafür braucht es die
Klarheit der Union und dafür werden wir
sie mit ihren Ankündigungen beim Wort
nehmen die Deutsche Islamkonferenz die
wurde 2006 gegründet als Forum für den
Dialog ja zwischen Staat und Muslimen
die nächste Islamkonferenz ist geplant
am 21 und 22 November und die
bundesinnenministerin nenn sie fer die
wird daran
teilnehmen schließen das heißt wer noch
nicht gewählt hat möge dies jetzt bitte
tun das Wort hat Helge Limburg für die
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
[Applaus]
grün vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der 7 Oktober
2023 ist eine zesur
der Tag des Beginns der brutalen
zutiefst Menschen verachtenden
Terrorangriffe der Hamas auf den Staat
Israel und seine Bewohnerinnen und
Bewohner ist nicht nur für Israel nicht
nur für Jüdin und Juden weltweit sondern
für die gesamte zivilisierte Welt ein
tiefer Einschnitt dieser Angriff galt
Israel er galt zu allererst Jüdinnen und
Juden aber er galt auch der modernen
Zivilisation er galt unserer Freiheit
unserer Demokratie und unser
Rechtsstaatlichkeit und es ist in der
Tat unerträglich dass es Menschen in
unserem Land gibt die diese Angriffe
bejubeln und
feiern die Forderung nach einem Kalifat
in Deutschland ist verfassungsfeindlich
ohne wenn und aber und entsprechende
Ansammlung müssen mit aller
Konsequenz unterbunden und geahet werden
Jüdin und Juden brauchen unseren Schutz
Islamismus Antisemitismus mussen aller
Entschiedenheit bekämpft werden aber
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wer wie die AFD den
Reichsbürger Putsch in den AFD
Funktionärin verwickelt waren verhamlust
wer stolz auf die whrmacht sein möchte
die in ganz Europa in die Verbrechen der
schoir des Holocaust der mordung der
Jüdin und Juden Europa verstrickt und
verwickelt war wer das Holocaust denkt
mal hier in Berlin verunglimpft der
beweist in der Tat dass es ihm nicht um
den Schutz unserer Demokratie unserer
Freiheit gilt der ist weder kohärent
noch glaubwürdig der will nur seine
eigene braune parteipolitische Suppe
kochen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen meine Damen und Herren
Islamismus ist eine Bedrohung für die
Freiheit Frau kardor hat es zurecht
gesagt die meisten Opfer islamistischen
Terrors und islamistischer Gewalt sind
Muslime in Syrien der Türkei dem Irak in
Afghanistan aber natürlich auch in den
Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika und auch
in der Europäischen Union sind immer
wieder auch Muslimin und Muslime Opfer
islamistisch Gewalt und Islamismus
greift auch nicht nur die Freiheit hier
bei uns an er unterdrückt da wo er es
kann in erster Linie Menschen
muslimischen Glaubens die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger des Iran in Afghanistan oder
auch im Gazastreifen müssen das seit
Jahren leidvoll ertragen und auch
deshalb ist es völlig fehlgeleitet die
notwendige Debatte um Islamismus mit
Hass und Hetze gegen Musliminnen und
Muslime zu
verknüpfen die die Strategie der
Bundesregierung von Ministerin fer ist
in der Tat die richtige nämlich auf der
einen Seite mit dialogformaten wie der
Islamkonferenz mit der Bekämpfung von
Islamfeindlichkeit zu agieren übrigens
auch die auch die Strategie von
vergangenen Bundesregierung das will ich
ausdrücklich würdigen und auf der
anderen Seite vereinigen zu verbieten
und zu verfolgen die sich hier dem
Islamismus verschrienen haben die
jüngsten Schritte Vereins und
betätigungsverbote gegen samidu und
Hamas waren die konsequente
Weiterführung dieser Doppelstrategie
meine Damen und
Herren frau Präsidentin meine Damen und
Herren wenn Sie allerdings der Kollege
amtor hier von gescheiterter linker
Integrationspolitik
reden dann frage ich mich schon wo sie
eigentlich in den vergangenen 16 Jahren
waren als ihre Partei die
Bundesregierung angeführt hat wo woher
amtor war denn die Union als sie von
2005 bis 2010 und ab seit 2017 wieder in
Nordrein-Westfalen wo ja die jüngsten
aufmchen wesentlich stattgefunden haben
wo sie Nordwestfalen regiert haben wo
war denn da ihre integrationpolitik
woher amtor war denn ihre
Integrationspolitik als sie in Berlin
ich finde viel zu lange aber in Berlin
den Regierenden Bürgermeister gestellt
haben und lange Jahre auch den
Innensenator dieser Stadt Herr amtor das
ist ein billiger Trick sich so zu
versuchen aus der Verantwortung zu
stellen eine Partei die so lange regiert
hat ist es ein bisschen albern und
unwürdig meine Damen und Herren wenn wir
über Strafverfolgung reden ist es immer
sehr spät wir brauchen doch Prävention
wir brauchen soziale Infrastruktur wir
brauchen Bildung wir brauchen echte
Aufstiegsmöglichkeiten für alle
unabhängig von Herkunft und Glaube
Debatten um Quoten in Stadtteilen oder
in Schulen führen nicht weit Investition
in soziale Infrastruktur führen unsere
Gesellschaft
zusammen frau Präsidentin meine Damen
und Herren Islamisten haben mit
Rechtsextremisten jeglicher kouur mehr
gemeinsam als es angesichts der Hetze
beider Seiten auf den Anschein hat beide
auch darauf hat Frau kador völlig
zurecht hingewiesen verachten
individuelle Freiheit die
Gleichberechtigung der Geschlechter
Frauenrechte queres Leben Demokratie
Rechtsstaatlichkeit beide verbreiten
Hass und Hetze gegen alle Menschen die
nicht ihre Auffassung sind
Menschenverachtung ist nicht von einer
Religion allein gepachtet wir antworten
diesen Hass mit dem was der Rechtsstaat
schon immer in seinem Instrumentenkasten
hatte nämlich Härte Konsequenz und
Klarheit gegen Straftaten und jegliche
Form von Hass und Hetze und mit Vielfalt
Offenheit und Toleranz für alle Formen
von Glauben und auch nicht glauben mit
der Härte des Rechtsstaat mit der
Vielfältigkeit des Grundgesetzes vielen
Dank meine Damen und
Herren hegelinburg war das für
die Zuschauer ich grüße Sie alle erst
einmal ganz herzlich an diesem
Donnerstag Nachmittag und Frage jetzt
auch gleich ist noch ein Mitglied des
Hauses anwesend dass seine Stimme bei
den Wahlen noch nicht abgegeben hat das
scheint nicht der Fall zu sein dann
schließe ich die Abstimmung und bitte
die Schriftführerin und Schriftführer
mit den Auszählungen zu beginnen das
Ergebnis geben wir dann später
bekannt hab gehört und gesehen die
Sitzungsleitung die
presidtinidöus und sie ruft den nächsten
Redner auf das ist aus den rein der FDP
Fraktion meine Damen und Herren wer in
Deutschland die Errichtung eines
Gottesstaates eines Kalifats fordert
muss die volollerhte unsere whrhaften
Demokratie die volle Härte unseres
Rechtsstaates zu spüren bekommen Punkt
das sind verstörende Bilder die wir
damit ansehen mussen das sind Bilder die
mit freier Meinungsäußerung und leg
Demonstrationen und mit Menschlichkeit
nichts zu tun haben das sind Bilder die
Angst machen die wütend machen und zwar
die überwältigende Mehrheit der Menschen
in unserem Land die Millionen muslimer
die religiösen Radikalen die den Islam
missbrauchen verachten all jene die vor
dem is und dem Terror vor genau diesen
Leuten zu uns geflohen sind und vor
diesen Menschen Verächtern Schutz
gesucht haben nicht alle Menschen sind
gleich aber alle die in diese Schublade
geworfen werden ist einfach falsch denn
jüdischen Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürger
in unserem Land den ich am heutigen 9
November dem jahrestag der
Reichspogromnacht gar nicht deutlich
genug sagen kann wir Demokraten stehen
zusammen egal welche Herkunft egal
welche Religion Muslim Jude oder Christ
wir lassen uns nicht aufhetzen Hass und
Hetzer haben bei uns keinen Platz das
wird zurecht immer gerne hochgehoben
aber Hass und Hetzer das ist das
Schlimme lassen sich nicht einfach
verbieten die Krisen dieser Zeit von
Corona
reichstagsstürmern über den Überfall
Russlands auf die Ukraine und nun das
Massaker der Hamas vergiften unsere
Gesellschaft wir sehen dass es immer
mehr Spaltung gibt immer mehr
gegeneinander immer mehr Teilung in
Schwarz und Weiß und auch der Ton der
Politiker in diesen Debatten Spalten
weiter für geistige
Brandstifter und Extremisten ist das ein
Geschenk für die Fraktion ganz rechts
von mir ist das das
Geschäftsmodell als demokratischer
Abgeordnete dieses Hauses als deutschees
Staatsbürger und als Patriot sage ich in
allen sage ich allen Extremisten und
radikalen in alle Deutlichkeit wir haben
keine Angst vor euch und euren Hass
damit wird Ihr nicht D wir werd ihr
verlieren das einzige was zählt ist dass
wir friedlich in unser Demokratie
zusammenleben wollen dass wir diesen
Willen diesen Frieden und unsere
Demokratie auch
verteidigen und darauf können Sie sich
verlassen
egal bei welchen Demokratie und
menschenfeinden sie mitmarschieren die
menschenwürder und wir Demokraten sind
stärker das ist meine Überzeugung vielen
Dank als nächstes erhält das Wort
mechthilde Wittmann für die CDU CSU
Fraktion
danke Frau Präsidentin Frau
Bundesministerin Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die aktuellen Geschehnisse auf
den deutschen Straßen mit die einem sehr
dynamischen Demonstrationsgeschehen
besorgen uns alle die Gewährung der
demokratischen Grundrechte der Meinungs
und Versammlungsfreiheit wird nicht
schrankenlos gewährt eine Schranke diese
Grundrechte ist ein wirksamer Schutz der
Menschen in unserem Land sowie unsere
Einrichtungen und unsere Institutionen
und diese rechtsgüte in Ausgleich zu
bringen nennt das
Bundesverfassungsgericht praktische
Konkordanz bei einer praktisch
konkordantischen abwgung kann man
schlechterdings eben nicht dazu kommen
dass die gerade zu tobenden
islamistischen Bekenntnisse gegen die
Grundwerte der deutschen Gesellschaft in
diesem unfassbaren Ausmaß auf deutschen
Straßen noch vom Grundgesetz gedeckt
werden es ist eine unschöne Mischung aus
neu legal oder illegal eingewandert
Antisemitismus mit den Menschen die
diese Haltung auch nach mehreren
Generationen in unserem Land nicht
aufgegeben haben die sich nur in ihrem
eigenen Kulturkreis integriert haben die
Durchsetzung hohheitliche Gewalt in
unserem demokratischen aber eben auch
unserem sekularen Rechtsstaat ist den
staatlichen Institutionen und nur diesen
zugewiesen das hat niemand egal ob
deutschstämmig oder nicht in Frage
zuellen und es ist Primat der Politik
dies über die Parteigrenzen hinaus zu
garantieren die Rechte einer Religion
sind im Grundgesetz geregelt und hier
passt es nicht zur Glaubwürdigkeit
einzelner muslimischer Verbände wenn
diese sich von den Gewalttaten der Hamas
einfach nicht abgrenzen können teilweise
sich sogar solidarisch mit dieser
terroristischen Organisation zeigen und
dabei nicht eine Silbe des Mitleids mit
den Opfern dieses Terrors in Israel
äußern und es kann in keinem Fall von
uns geduldet werden dass einzelne
Angehörige dieser Religion zur
Abschaffung der staatlichen Gewalt in
Deutschland unter Ausnutzung der
versammlungsrechte ausrufen und dabei
rücksichtslos die große friedliebende
Mehrheit ihre Religion in Misskredit
bringen Antisemitismus hat in diesem
Land keine Platz und muss schwer
bestraft werden und es wird und darf
nicht geduldet werden dass Jüdinnen und
Juden sich bei uns nicht mehr sicher
fühlen dafür braucht es Handlungsbedarf
und dafür muss Antisemitismus als
besonders schwerer Fall der
Volksverhetzung eingestuft werden das
aufenhaltsgesetz muss geändert werden
das antisemitische Straftaten zu einer
regelhaften Ausweisung führen und soweit
es doppelstaatsangehörige betrifft
braucht es die erleichterte Möglichkeit
eines passentzugs bei antisemitistischen
Straftaten an diesem vorgehen muss die
Bundesregierung unverzüglich arbeiten
und daran Frau fer wird sie gemessen um
es noch einmal klar zu sagen eine
Einbürgerung von Personen die an
gewaltsamen antisemitischen
Demonstrationen teilnehmen und dieses
Gedankengut auch noch propagieren darf
es nicht geben und wer die staatliche
Gewalt in Deutschland nicht anerkennt
kann durch die staatlichen Stellen auch
keine Staatsbürgerschaft erhalten und in
den Schutzstatus dieser
Staatsbürgerschaft
gelangen und in diesem Sinn muss die ne
zum Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht dringend
überdenken es genügt nicht wenn das
bundesinnministerium noch immer nicht
darlegen kann wie viele volksverhetzende
Straftaten islamistisch oder
salafistisch motiviert sind Bund und
Länder haben einen polizeilichen
informations und analyseverbund über den
sich diese statistische Auswertung
technisch automatisch auslösen lässt und
auch das Bundeskriminalamt ist mit
entsprechenden Fähigkeiten und
Befugnissen
ausgestattet was braucht es also noch um
uns belastbare Zahlen zu diesen
Straftaten zu nennen sie zu benennen und
vor allem die richtigen Konsequenzen zu
ziehen und wir erwarten dass die
unerträglichen Vorgänge auf diesen
Straßen durch den Staatsschutz vorrangig
ermittelt und als solche auch vorrangig
zur Anklage gebracht und abgeurteilt
werden hier GT es mit der vollen herte
des Rechtsstaats ein Zeichen für den
Wertekanon in unserem Land auch vor dem
Hintergrund unserer Geschichte kraftvoll
unmissverständlich und sichtbar in die
Welt zu senden diese antisemitischen
Aufmärsche die sich unter dem Deckmantel
der Versammlungsfreiheit organisieren
müssen wir zum Anlass nehmen
rechtsstaatliche antworten auf solche
Entwicklungen zu finden das
Versammlungsrecht ist grundsätzlich
Sache der Länder aber wir finden in acht
Bundesländern immer noch kein
Versammlungsrecht weswegen hier das
bundesversammlungsgesetz Anwendung
findet und daher besteht eben
Handlungsbedarf des Bundes und auf
diesen bestehen wir und den erwarten wir
von
ihen wir fragen uns warum prüfen Sie
nicht ein Versammlungsverbot für solche
versammlungsanmeldungen bei denen zu
befürchten ist dass antisemitische
Straftaten oder Aufrufe zum Kalifat
erfolgen werden dies wäre doch eine
einfache Änderung von Paragraph 15 des
Versammlungsgesetzes machbar und ich
würde mir wünschen dass wir diese
Änderung des Gesetzes möglichst schnell
auf den Tisch bekommen meine Damen und
Herren jüdisches Leben ist eine
Bereicherung in unserer Gesellschaft
und das werden wir mit allen Mitteln der
Politik und unserer Rechtsordnung
hoffentlich gemeinsam
durchsetzen mächthilde Wittmann war das
für die Union und während ihres
Vortrages doch teilweise wees
Kopfschütteln der bundesinnenministerin
neny Fazer die hier auf der
Regierungsbank Platz genommen hat als es
darum ging sie könne keine
entsprechenden Zahlen vorlegen aber
jetzt hat noch mal eine Gelegenheit zur
Erwiderung für die SPD Sebastian Fiedler
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren die AFD
bringt heute ein Thema der inneren
Sicherheit hier auf die Tagesordnung und
schickt zwei interessante Redner ins
Rennen der erste spricht von Freiheit
Ordnung und Normalität und Deutschland
ist unser Land hat sich aber in der
Vergangenheit an huligen Schlägereien
beteiligt bei ihm zu Hause fand die
Polizei ein T Teleskopschlagstock eine
Sturmhaube und trophäenfotos wurde vom
Landgericht Mainz verurteilt wegen
Beihilfe zur Körperverletzung zuur 90
tagessetzen a 180 €. das ist Ordnung und
Normalität der AFD der zweite Redner
spricht von einer Schande für
Deutschland in meinem Berufsstand finde
ich Polizisten in rechtsextrem Parteien
sind eine Schande für
Deutschland und ich verstehe ehrlich
gesagt die Texte gar nicht so richtig
weil die Innenministerin ist in ihrer
Haltung völlig klar und jetzt ich habe
gar nicht so viel Zeit um alles wieder
auseinander zu fen auch Frau witmann in
Nord westfahen gibt's ein
landesversammlungsgesetz in soweit
verstehe ich den Zusammenhang zu den
heutigen Demonstrationen hier gar nicht
nicht wie passt das irgendwie zusammen
da könnten wir über Herbert re
diskutieren würde ich jetzt aber gar
nicht machen jedenfalls viele dieser
Rechtsgebiete sind eben Landesrecht
Gefahrenabwehrrecht ist Landesrecht aber
vor allen Dingen will ich erstmal den
Text voranstellen unsere Demokratie ist
wehrhaft und die Polizei macht eine
vernünftige Arbeit die Versammlungen
werden von den versammlungsbehörden
selbstverständlich zunächst einmal
überprüft wenn die Anträge reinkommen
sie glauben doch nicht ernsthaft dass
die Polizei nachlässig solche
Versammlung genehmigt das gegen il
dürfte der Fall sein übrigens auch in
Essen und natürlich versucht man dann
solche Versammlung zu verbieten wenn es
rechtliche Möglichkeiten gibt aber wir
sollten die Dinge schon beim Namen
benennen wir alle wollen mit den Mitteln
des Rechtsstaates die Dinge die wir hier
zure recht anprangern bekämpfen und
nicht mit flotten Sprüchen die wir ja
einfach in den Raum
hauen und wenn eine solche Versammlung
erlaubt werden muss dann arbeitet die
Versammlungsbehörde mit Auflagen und die
werden natürlich jetzt wie das immer bei
der Polizeiarbeit ist nachgearbeitet man
wird bei künftigen Versammlungen neu ne
Auflagen haben man wird dann
einschreiten es gibt entsprechende
Strafverfahren man arbeitet mit
Beweissicherung man arbeitet mit der
Auflösung von Versammlungen man kann auf
der einen Seite und muss auf der einen
Seite die Dinge die passiert sind
anprangern auf der anderen Seite aber
doch eben sagen wir leben doch hier
nicht im luftleeren Raum sondern in
einer wehrhaften Demokratie und in einem
Rechtsstaat und an der Stelle muss man
eben sagen tun wir ja an vielen anderen
Stellen besonders viel der
Verfassungsschutz darf noch erwähnt
werden die Polizeibehörden habe ich
erwähnt wir haben spezialisiert
Staatsanwaltschaften der General
Bundesanwalt ist unterwegs und was mir
heute so ein bisschen fehlt ist all
denjenigen Menschen die in den
Sicherheitsbehörden die jeden Tag den
Hintern aufreißen einmal herzlich Danke
zu sagen für das was sie jeden Tag
tun und das tun wir nicht nur repressiv
sondern eben auch präventiv da ist schon
vieles gesagt worden aber da ist noch
ein bisschen Luft nach oben die
Präventionsmaßnahmen müssen besser
harmonisiert werden wir müssen sie
besser evaluieren und deswegen machen
wir uns auf den Weg eine eigene
Bundesakademie aufzustellen die genau
diese Koordinierung noch mal an den Tag
legt und hier noch ein Stück weit besser
zu werden aber ich will diese aktuelle
Stunde nicht beenden um noch einmal zu
sagen wir sind heute 85 Jahre am 9
November nach der reichsprogumnach ein
Tag an dem sich eigentlich solche
Debatten verbieten meine Vorrednerin hat
das schon gesagt ein Tag der Trauer des
Gedenkens und des innerhaltens ein Tag
an dem wir uns daran erinnern müssen
dass sowas von sowas kommt unser
heutiges Deutschland bekämpft
Extremisten mit den Mitteln des
Rechtsstaates und der Demokratie und
unsere Sicherheitsbehörden haben die
volle Rückendeckung wenn der Gesetzgeber
hier Nachschärfen muss dann tut er das
und das tun wir und das will ich am Ende
dieser Debatte noch mal sagen indem alle
von uns zumindest alle die auf diesen
Seiten des Parlaments sitzen das tun
indem sie den Respekt und die Würde
jedes einzelnen Menschen in den
Mittelpunkt stellen indem sie
Chancengleichheit und Vielfalt beachten
indem sie aktiv eintreten gehen jede
Form von Rassismus und heute besonders
Antisemitismus fremdenfeinlichkeit
Diskriminierung und Ausgrenzung wir
verteidigen die freiheitlich
demokratische Grundordnung wir behandeln
alle Menschen gleich unabhängig von
ihrem Alter ihrem Geschlecht ihrer
sozialen ethnischen und kulturellen
Herkunft Weltanschauung Religion
politischen Überzeugung und sexuellen
Orientierung das ist unser
Deutschland für die SPD letzter Redner
hier in dieser aktuellen Stunde bevor er
in den Bundestag eingezogen ist war er
Bundesvorsitzender des bundesdeutscher
Kriminalbeamter auch zum Teil als
Landesvorsitzender in nordrin Westfalen
um noch einmal zur umstrittenen
Demonstration in Essen zu kommen die ja
anlass dieser aktuellen Stunde war dort
werden jetzt Videos und Fotos
ausgewertet von der Polizei mit
Unterstützung von dolmitch und
Islamwissenschaftlern es geht darum sind
da verbotene Symbole gezeigt worden und
gegen einen Redner wird bereits wegen
Volksverhetzung ermittelt